this is the thing about being  progressive  and being woke and all that [ __ ]  [ __ ] right  the the young generations the  millennials what you're missing out on  is right that let old people be [ __ ]  old right they'll be dead soon enough  right stop [ __ ] making everyone move  as fast as you're [ __ ] moving right  people  are trying right here's the thing about  millennials  you're the worst people that have ever  lived  you're the worst you're just a horrible  breed of people and i don't even blame  you  it's just the society you're in you have  social media every single peanut [ __ ]  thought that ever came into your head oh  [ __ ] comment  what type of [ __ ] low rent [ __ ] to  you  like if you take more than  three selfies a week [ __ ] end it end  it